let's talk about taking a break from the
job search during the holidays
welcome back to another episode of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and this week we're chatting
about something I know is lingering
somewhere in the back of your mind
taking a break from the job search
during the holidays now this is
something that I come across every
single year around this time we're
working really hard on their job search
strategy and right as we get into the
holiday spirit they decide it's time to
take a break to hibernate until the new
year and everyone has a different reason
why they tell me no one is hiring they
say that people won't respond to their
emails they lament that no one is in the
office and no one wants to network
during the holiday season
however while all of these people are
cozying up in their pajamas and pouring
their cups of hot cocoa
you know what's happening all the
dedicated jobseekers are out there
snatching up the golden opportunities
these folks realize that not everyone is
out of the office and that those who are
still in the office might be feeling a
bit lonely and would love to take a half
hour out of their day to get peppermint
lattes and chat about their career they
also realize that there's this whole
other group of job seekers that have
taken the month off which means that the
jobs that are posted and the companies
that are hiring have much lower numbers
of applications coming in which means
competition is low and they're going to
be much higher in the consideration for
whatever jobs they're applying for and
finally these folks also know that the
first few weeks back after the new year
are the messiest weeks of the year
everyone is trying to catch back up on
email and get back into the speed of
things and all the job seekers are now
blasting every company with their
resumes which means competition is going
to be crazy those first few weeks of the
new year and that this is the best time
to get ahead of that rush these
dedicated job seekers do not slow down
during the holidays they speed up now it
doesn't mean you shouldn't enjoy time
with your family and it doesn't mean you
can't open some great presents and drink
some great hot cocoa but it does mean
that if Santa can circle the world in
one night you can keep
job search going through the holidays
thank you so much for watching I truly
appreciate you taking the time to watch
these videos and put these ideas into
practice please share your experiences
in the comments and if you know anyone
who is searching for a job right now
tag them below and let them know that
you're thinking about it we wish you the
best of luck in your job search and a
happy holiday season